if you've been anywhere from the
beginning of this game to roughly the
first week of foreigner you know that
it's had a very interesting launch since
the beginning with players disconnecting
every match to unbalanced heroes such as
peacekeeper the fan base game had been
screwed over $60 some of the players not
even receiving their benefits of paying
more than 60 for the game the causes of
the has a half-ass attempt to fix the
game's problems to the developers
completely ignoring the fan base
entirely which almost caused a
widespread blackout where players
refused to play this game for 24 hours
or more just so Ubisoft could listen to
us what we had to say but after all of
this happening I think starting to look
good for for honor and its community as
a whole in my absolute honest opinion I
completely believe so not just because
of a for honoured youtuber and had to
kiss Ubisoft ass they don't care what I
have to say and if they have enough they
have a problem with me fine but if
there's a problem with them that needs
to be addressed I will call them out on
it even if it means that being that
problem being fixed in a later patch
you've seen my videos before I call that
Ubisoft for their absurd amount of Steel
for all these different executions and
all the new outfits so no I'm not just
kissing our half there but seriously the
Ubisoft has greatly improved this game
from what it used to be like I said it
used to had unbalanced heroes like
peacekeeper and absolutely no
communication with their fan base
now here's who our top tier being nerfed
in those characters who need those buffs
such as Berserker are getting those
buffs they just recently know if the
wardens shoulder - although it wasn't a
huge nerf it was definitely a difference
to the player and play in his play style
of warden they even nerfed Peacekeeper
making her second light attack just
slowing up the block and parry so that
she can be less opie but not too much
that she's a low tier hero on top of
that the devs have had weekly live
streams which used to be dueling BOTS
for an hour and talking about post
patches now they're answering questions
that we have on reddit sharing news and
updates about specific dates and those
releases even the even teasing the DLC
heroes centering and shinobi just
recently now Ubisoft has even shown us
pictures of the new ranked emoticons for
all the game modes meaning ranked is
definitely confirmed and it will further
enhance this player base because now
players have another incentive or reason
to play this game which would be ranking
up the diamond tier to recover that
exclusive reward at the end of the
season although in my opinion Ubisoft
has definitely made an improvement for
this game the connection still hasn't
been completely fixed for all players
people are still being discounted for
matches but to be fair it's not as often
as it used to be but if range mode would
be released it wouldn't be as enjoyable
as you think it would be usually when
you think of a ranked game you think of
a lot of League of Legend tournaments
some csgo tournaments and how they do
really well with their competitive game
mode
the problem with ranked for for honor is
the constant disconnecting mid match can
cause players to lose a rein can
possibly be ranked into another division
losing the reward but there is nothing I
want more for this game to be successful
as Rainbow six siege as Rainbow six
siege has been out for almost a year and
instead of dwindling this player base
slowly and slowly it's actually gaining
more players each day I really do hope I
see for honor do the same but anyway
guys it's going to be my short little
discussion video I won't hear all of
your thoughts whether you think
foreigners been improving as a game or
not if it's been if it hasn't been for
you if it has been I want to hear your
comments down below I know this is a
little bit of a different video had to
feel-good music oh and had a big long
paragraph of a script heavily scripted
video for you all but I just want to
understand I want to get this out here
and I want to hear all of your thoughts
I'm once again why you think is it
getting better is it getting worse and
do you think it will be better in the
future kind of like covering those six
each as anyway guys I'll see you all
Thursday for the dead stream when it
comes out and peace out voice